believe it or not in today's video I'm going to
teach you guitarists how to play from a 400 year
old lutet manuscript in my last video we learned
all about the history of tablature and that it was
actually the dominant type of notation used for
lute's, guitars, theorbos and more from 1400 to
1800 and we also learned that there are so many
digitized manuscripts out there books and books
of music that you can play from so today I've
picked a very easy but very sad and beautiful
piece called Mr Dowland's midnight by the famous
Elizabethan lute player John Dowland by the end
of this video my hope is to teach you how to
play directly from the 400 year old man script
before we dive in if you missed the last video
on the history of tablature I'd highly recommend
starting with that one there's a link for the
video in the description now for today's video
It Doesn't Matter What type of guitar you have
electric steel string flamenco jazz acoustic
classical they'll all work as long as I have six
strings now real quick in case you're not familiar
tablature is the main type of notation used by
guitars to play rock pop Folk and other styles
of guitar it's super super easy you have six
horizontal lines representing this six strings
of the guitar the line on top represents
your thinnest string the first string High e
the bottom line represents the low E the
sixth string we put numbers on those lines
which represent the Frets so if I had a
zero on the top line that would be the
first string open if I put a 1 on the top line
that would be the first fret on the first string
two is second fret 3 is third four five six
hopefully you get the idea if understanding
modern guitar tab is new to you I'd encourage
you to go check out other videos which teach this
topic and then come back here when you're ready
and if you understand modern guitar tab then today
is going to be easy for you so here's our piece Mr
Dowland's midnight on a lute it sounds like this
[Music]
as you can see it's sad short and beautiful while
this manuscript of French tablature might look
difficult let me just quickly show you what this
would look like in modern tap suddenly the music
looks not so difficult and while you could play
just from this you could then only play one piece
I want to give you the tools so you can play all
loot music from the manuscript now if you watch my
history of tablature video you'll notice that we
still have six lines here in our manuscript these
six lines represent the strings and they're
in the same orientation the one at the top is
the first string our high a string in this case
then we have letters representing Frets instead
of numbers this is called French tablature so if
we were on the first string a is the open first
string zero B is the first fret c d e f and we
don't need anything higher than F the fifth fret
for this piece now before we start plucking out
some notes we need to change one thing about your
guitar so it can become a loot our third string
on a guitar is G but to play all of the beautiful
flute music you see from 1400 to 1600 all
you have to do is take your third string
and bring it down to F sharp the easiest
way to do that is to play your open second
string and then to play the fifth fret on
the third string and make those sound the
same so normally it would sound like this and
then you can tune it your third string down
until they sound good together now your third
string is an F sharp and from here on out we can
forget about note names and Harmony on all that of
course the next step in your musical practice will
be to understand the notes and the harmony but
just to play the piece we don't need it now the
next thing we need to quickly explain is that in
the manuscript the letters that look like an R are
actually C's so those are all second Frets also
this little squiggle here is an F in different
manuscripts you'll see different handwriting and
we have to get used to the person's handwriting
about what they mean when but to be honest you get
used to this really fast when you look through a
whole book and once you know what symbols mean
which letter it's very easy we can officially
now play our first chord we have a note on the
fifth string So reading from the the bottom to
the top fifth string we have that R remember
that means C so fifth string is an open a on
the guitar a b c is the second fret so C on
the second fret with your thumb plucking in
the right hand then I see two A's above that
an A on the third string an A on the second
string and because they're vertically aligned it
means we should play all those at the same time
I should note that you're going to have to use
the fingers on your right hand to pluck using
a pick isn't going to work we're going to worry
about Rhythm later but let's keep learning some
notes after that first chord we then have a r on
the second string remember that's a c so I'm going
to call it a c for now on so second fret on the
second string I'd play that with my middle finger
of my left hand so so far [Music] more about the
other markings in a bit but let's get playing a
bit more the third note says D on the second
string so a b c d That's our third fret [Music]
and now another open second string
so the first measure [Music]
the second measure starts in a similar way we
still have our index finger down on this second
fret of the fifth string open third string
and now we have to play a d the third fret
of the second string next is an open first string
followed by an open third string a and a c on the
which is the second fret of the second string
those are vertically aligned again so we play
them together I'm playing with i and m index and
middle in the right hand so the second measure
and the last note of the second
measure is a b so a is open B is
the first fret of the fifth string
the second measure again foreign
let's do two whole measures
very slowly ready go [Music]
if I'm playing too fast or slow go ahead and use
the gear icon at the bottom to speed up or slow
down based on your needs the third measure is
almost the same as the first one except at the
end the fourth beat we have a c again the second
fret of the second string and an open fifth string
they're vertically aligns they play together
okay three measures in a row ready go [Music]
foreign last measure of the a section we have this
chord so we have a d on the sixth string a b c d d
is the third fret B on the third string D on the
second string at this point if you're thinking
man reading this manuscript is so hard because
the letters are hard to read here is a modern
version of the exact same thing we're seeing I'll
make this downloadable so again on that third
measure simultaneous so it's a chord followed by
an open first string a and we have another chord
second fret of the sixth string that's a
c then we have e on the third string so
a b c d e and then we have the first and the
second string have a c on them second Frets so
you can plug in the right hand thumb
index middle ring and we have to Bar
everything in the left hand good news we
have four measures let's play them ready go
[Music]
how beautiful is that you're playing from a
400 year old manuscript so if you got this
far give yourself a pat on the back already
I don't know about you but I think this is
so cool and it's a beautiful experience
you might be noticing that for the chords
I arpeggiate I roll the chords rather than
playing chunk this is called rolling accord
or arpeggiating and it can be a really
nice effect on the guitar or the loot
foreign
word arpeggio is actually what inspired the name
for my online music school rpajanto this is an
online school for plucked instruments and if you'd
like to learn a plucked instrument like Guitar
ukulele bass loot or more or delve deeper into
the subject of tablature we have an assortment
of specialists in various instruments and styles
who can give you weekly lessons on Zoom so please
check out ourpajato.com to learn more now the
second section we can call it the B section is
almost the same as the first it's a variation on
the first section so it starts the same but then
you're actually seeing the manuscript there's
an a written below the staff here we went
into a problem some loots in the Renaissance
had seven strings so in this case that's the
seventh string it would have sounded like a low
D the easiest solution when you see things like
this is just to either not play it or take it
up the octave in this case it's the same note
as this first thing you play but you don't have
the lower version so we can just play this twice
and get a similar effect now loots from the
Renaissance to the Baroque Period came in
many shapes and sizes this is a late Styler this
is a baroque style loot so we call this one an
arch loot or a luto atir Bato it has 14 courses
14 pairs of strings so it gets very very low
and these are the types of low notes that
you'd reach down to if you see that there
are letters below the tablature in the case of Mr
darling's midnight that low note would sound like
so in context [Music]
but as I said we're just going to repeat
that note and it still sounds nice
and everything is the same until the fourth
measure of the B section instead
of playing we have a little scale
your middle finger on the third fret it says
D on the sixth string then we play an open
a on the second that's the open string then
while holding your second finger down we play
C D or two three [Music] and the A on the first
means open so and then that same chord we ended
on the first section all right now we have two
sections let's hear them again ready go foreign
[Music]
there's one more section to the piece
we can call it the C-section and then
that'll be it here we have a on
the third string C on the second
string so zero two followed by f f is the
fifth fret remember on the first string
okay then D is the third fret
on the third string C open
second fret is C to the first measure [Music]
going on we have second fret on the
fourth string open second string
D is the third fret of the first string
two zero okay this is a funny one we have f
f d five five three and then two zero or c a
so the second measure
let's play the first two
measures slowly ready go [Music]
so I'm picking up the pace here you might need to
pause and practice this a bit to keep up at this
point third measure of the C-section open fourth
string that's a c is the second fret so our chord
[Music] like that A C or zero two on the first
string [Music] now we have c c a or two two zero
f d or five three okay so measure four of
the C-section we have c a c two zero three
see again and then the chord we started with
you'll notice I'm starting to pick up the pace
even more you're not meant to necessarily learn
the whole song Perfectly in real time of this
video rewind replay practice come back and
you'll be able to do this for sure going on
on the first string CD 2 3 next measure f f is
five open third string so zero five or AF d c
DNA three zero or a d a c with theater second
finger holding the third fret of the third string
now really saves time if you can notice patterns
so this next chord we're about to play we've
already played it once so try to notice that the
second measure of this section is the same chord c
a d and it even continues the same C A and now
the D the third fret of the sixth string D on
the second string with a little scale d c d a and
again we have this chord which we saw already in
the third measure of this section A D C it's a D
major chord a c d with a low e lower we call it a
in a tablature d c a d last measure C four two two
c a c and then the chord we started with [Music]
again you won't learn this in real time
perfectly use the gear icon replay the video
um practice the song a bit the point here is
not to master at first try it's to understand
how to read the notation and then open up
an infinite realm of tablature to play from
manuscripts from 400 years ago so practice
what we just learned walk through the piece
until this seems easy use my modern computer
versions if you have to but my recommendation
is don't use the numbers use the letters
the French tablature so you can really play
from The Originals congrats on learning to
play the 400 year old notes from Mr dowlins
midnight today next week in part two we're
going to learn how to play The rhythms and
then talk about which fingers you should use
if you enjoyed today's video make sure you
subscribe and hit the Bell so you don't miss
other videos I post like this one if you want
to help me make more videos like this you can
go to my patreon and there you'll find lots of
behind the scenes content about what I'm up to
the videos I'm making performances I'm giving
and you'll receive rewards like early viewing all
my videos my CDs and you can even get a private
lesson with me and lastly if you're interested in
learning classical guitar especially at your own
pace at home I have a beginner online classical
guitar course called classical guitar Pro it's six
hours long 53 videos so I hope you'll check that
out until next time thanks for watching [Music]
foreign [Music]